how's game resumes beautiful welcome
back to the forest so they finally
updated the game so you can actually
save how about that what what is this
can I sleep in them now that'd be too
easy wouldn't it why would I use someone
else tents when I can build my own
hunting lodge let's do that Prez
so anyway hopefully now we can actually
do a series of this game because now you
can save alright we'll be fine in this
forest price we're gonna survive it for
as long as possible which let's be
honest and probably won't be more than
two days
alright let's build our little hunting
shelter where should we build impress up
here on the clip yeah that's good
shut up god damn this breath scares me
man stop having a breath seriously stop
breathing scare the [ __ ] out of me all
right perfect
okay come on you're my dinner come on
come on me you're my friend I'm kidding
eat my dinner I'm gonna need you just a
little bit just a tail come on hey they
can teleport come on come on Lizzie
Lizzie Lizzie
don't be come here don't be scared don't
be scared I'm just gonna [ __ ] murder
you I skinned him oh nice a skinned
lizard you are my dear friend The
Adventures of Lizzie had pits all right
let's focus here because we don't want
to die but at least we have a friend now
it's important oh they climbed it Leslie
what are you doing climbing the trees
stupid stupid Lizzie I think she's all
hipster a cool intro climbing trees and
[ __ ] gravity defying lizards these days
they don't understand they don't do
anything for society there we go so now
we can sleep unless we update the game
thanks thanks thanks oh god was that
already god they're coming already get
off my chest I'm mad I'm a battery what
are you doing get off stupid [ __ ]
what should we do next
and I will shut up build a fire you
should be at the fair bet
all right that's what we're gonna do
that what about coins it's the baby
oh all right that makes sense is that
good Lizzie yes yes it's very good Pete
where do I say Lex defied a shallow shut
up Lizzie you know you know you don't
know who you are you're you're you're a
confused teenager oh that makes ID all
right
oh you can find Lizzie you can swim
Lizzie Wow you can do so many things
Lizzie if only I knew you're my best
friend's Lizzie I am the spirit of
Stefano
oh all right well that's colon or you
can't eat those you die oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] Lizzie what happened Lizzie Lizzie
don't run away don't escape from me dad
effect no I loved me get off my chair
okay let's build our fire and then it
looks like we have to sleep because we
are low on energy
all right let's go to bed first night
baby we did it all right Lizzie where
where - this way P it's all right
whatever you say we need to find some
food what is that a hat it's a hat for
Lizzie you look great in it
what is this listen oh this is Lizzie's
mom oh damn your mom so fat man Jesus
disgusting oh gosh shark woody I'm what
[ __ ] attention lately what do you do
with genetics no one updates I use the X
it's called the Lex
oh my god that's amazing
you're the best Lizzie you're my best
friend let's find some food we really
need to find some food man blueberries
awesome
let's eat all of them oh god what was
that oh god I think they saw me
this is this is very bad hold me Lizzie
you're holding me Oh God was that okay
ducks okay at anything but the decks
oh I don't like that oh [ __ ] they saw me
run run they cray cray cray okay
fight me in real life okay I think we
trust them I think we test them really
good right Leslie they say I mean yes
sorry I was checking my facebook Botha
oh there's their boss [ __ ] let's stay
out away from there we better get back
it'd be cool if they like shut up
what is that sound who makes sound oh no
oh no we'd better go we'd better go we'd
better go would have better get a bit a
bit of almond zetas better stay away oh
wait uh come at me bro come at me
tip it out Geoff tits they're scary
they're all saggy wear a bra for God's
sake
you [ __ ] oh you damn you damn you still
[ __ ] gay or you get all mad you can
run okay okay okay
oh god I think I killed a stick okay
okay okay
Lizzie you're awesome good job it's huh
Lizzie Lizzie wish Oh Lizzie you're back
what the [ __ ]
scared me for taking iPads sorry I was
just checking my Twitter
all right that's that's okay I guess
what do we got here this is a comp
flashlight
awesome awesome yeah awesome rez you're
doing great oh we can make effigies what
the [ __ ] I don't think it's a good idea
to use this Alice build them and we're
back let's cook some food let's cook
this bunny Oh Oh see oh it's so cute I'm
sorry I can't get all these records why
birds why how long does it have to cook
oh oh okay that's cool what the [ __ ] are
you doing what the hell are you guys
doing what is wrong with you my suicide
what are you doing stop it
what is this
what what wait why do they my suicide I
didn't kill him
what hilarious okay you know what let's
feel some work [ __ ] what if the hell is
this okay I don't know what it is but
I'm gonna build it okay what is this a
bench
I built a bench fantastic all right we
have a log holder now I don't know why
but we have it cloth plus booth makes a
Molotov we're gonna try that [ __ ] oh my
god that's gonna be awesome
all right it's done how does it work I
don't know I don't want to know okay oh
[ __ ] oh no Lizzie now all right cool it
works that's fantastic
I don't know why I have my little bench
I have my little damage my place let's
cook some bunny hey sis no no harm now
bunny
you be nice oh bloody time Wow
look what you did bunny look what you do
you son of a [ __ ] pour it all right you
know what I'm gonna have to eat Lizzie
now there you go
and leave Lisa will die like a man
except she's a woman well who knows
these days we should probably make a
garden yeah let's do that
pretty neat camp if I may say so much
safe all right
you know what we're gonna have to expand
here I think it's a bad time that we
kill some yes oh my god it's gonna be
awesome
No
why did I do that no Lacey what are you
doing here what are you doing what are
you doing climbing
marching with trees Lizzy's such a crazy
yeah whoa
okay that's give me a heart attack all
right let's kill some of them so I think
we should build one of those all right
here's a dead naked guy oh look I could
collect his ass oh my god what is
happening oh god this is like the egg of
doom
that's how you build [ __ ] all right
we're [ __ ] right there oh god no I
didn't see them no oh God
don't hurt me I'm Swedish where's my
house where's my [ __ ] house where is
it darkness go to the trap go to red go
to hell
look I made art you should be happy oh
god oh god they don't like art they
really don't like art I don't understand
it's made of their people I love that
guy just running around in circles
there is too much red Bowl on that guy
all right let's check out the boat
really quick yes III am aware seagulls
can do that good job seagull good job Oh
cloth cool now we can make a Molotov yes
all right
let's burn those [ __ ] oh they're
still there he's still running it around
oh my god this is perfect
all right let's do this let's make a
couple molotovs all right make it count
oh god I'm so nervous I'm so nervous all
right where did the other two did all
right there there come at me [ __ ] mother
of [ __ ] we're so [ __ ]
dad damn it that was the worst idea yes
yes burn oh god don't burn burn yes burn
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay hurry
hurry hurry hurry ma bring it oh you
have saggy tits [ __ ] you [ __ ] saggy
[ __ ] wear a bra you yes yes yes oh
it's the best Christmas present ever
where'd she go now come on I need their
head come on
oh she teleporting oh that's a good
great hi sir how is it hey glad to get
weather Hey oh [ __ ]
oh my god where's the head various don't
know although you dropped two heads
that's that's pretty good I guess yeah
oh my god oh my god we're done
Oh rainbow capel rainbow this one
rainbow whatever
that's alright let's take a swim and
then let's save all right Bryce I'm
gonna have to end this episode here I
hope you enjoyed watching I had a lot of
fun playing this game is actually really
fun once you get into it and it works
but yeah a new update comes out in eight
days so I think I'll wait a little bit
until I continue because I would pretty
much build everything we can build
except the house so I don't think that's
fun to watch anyway so looking like if
you are watching and help support the
series and health supports me and I
really appreciate it
so hits sky from Earth today and I'll
see you tomorrow